اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار الملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
الخارجيه الايرانيه تعلن ان وفدا ايرانيا
وصل الى الرياض لاعاده فتح السفاره
والقنصليه
السنه يقول بانه يتطلع للعمل مع الاداره
والكونغرس لتعزيز العلاقات مع الرياض
الامن العام السعودي يعلن عن ضبط 47 حمله
وهميه للعمره في مختلف المناطق
في الرابعه ايضا
عائله سعوديه تتولى اعداد وجبات الافطار
لعشرات الصائمين في عرعر منذ نحو عشره
اعوام
مركز استطلاعات الراي في السعوديه يكشف
بان واحد واربعين في المئه من الاشخاص لا
ينامون الليل في رمضان
حياكم الله اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني عن وصول
وفط ايراني الى السعوديه لاتخاذ الترتيبات
اللازمه لفتح سفاره ايران في الرياض
وقنصليتها في جده كنعان اوضح ايضا في
تصريحات نشرتها وسائل اعلاميه ان الوفد
سيبحث في السعوديه استئناف نشاط الممثليات
الايرانيه الدائمه في منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي مشيرا الى ان طهران تسعى لفتح
بعثاتها في السعوديه واستئناف نشاطها قبل
موسم الحج هذا وسيغادر الوقت الفني
السعودي الذي وصل الى ايران يوم السبت
الماضي سيغادر متوجها الى مشهد غدا لبحث
اعاده فتح القنصليه
هذا وشهدت منطقه الشرق الاوسط خلال الاشهر
الماضيه حراكا كبيرا باتجاه تسويه ملفات
عالقه بين دول المنطقه هذا التوجه نحو
التهدئه وخفض التصعيد ترجمه الحكومات
بزيارات متبادله وجلسات مباحثات ثنائيه
[موسيقى]
24 من نوفمبر عام 2021 محمد بن زايد يزور
تركيا وفي الرابع عشر من فبراير عام 2022
اردوغان يزور الامارات اما التاسع
والعشرون من ابريل عام 2022
اردوغان يزور السعوديه الثانيه والعشرون
من يونيو عام 2022 الامير محمد بن سلمان
يزور تركيا السابع والعشرون من فبراير عام
2023 وزير الخارجيه المصري يصل الى دمشق
السابع والعشرون من فبراير عام 2023 وزير
الخارجيه المصري يصل الى تركيا الثامنه
عشر من مارس عام 2023 وزير الخارجيه
التركي يصل الى القاهره اما العاشر من
مارس عام 2023 توقيع اتفاقيه بين السعوديه
وايران في شهر ابريل من العام الجاري وفد
سعودي عماني يصل الى صنعاء لبحث المدنه
بين اليمنيين
معنا الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث دكتور عبد العزيز مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض دكتور قطار المصالحات والسلام في
الشرق الاوسط لا يتوقف برايك ما الذي
يدفعه بهذه السرعه
وهل يعني الدفاع هذا القطار تصفير
الخلافات بين الدول التي كانت مختلفه او
التي كانت يعني على عدم توافق في كثير من
الملفات ام ان هذا الامر يعني تنظيم
الخلافات وتاجيلها برايك
اولا مساء الخير لكل المشاهدينك في كل
مكان
وتقبل الله الطاعات بالجميع على العموم
النقطه المهمه في هذا الجانب والنهار
هنالك توجه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تبناه صاحب السمو الملكي ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن سلمان في
ترتيب العلاقه الاقليميه حينما شعر انه لا
يمكن الاعتماد على العلاقه الدوليه
الخارجيه في ترتيب قضايا المنطقه فوجد ان
الاصلح والاوفى هو ترتيب العلاقه
الاقليميه في المنطقه بدايه من العراق
وايضا بعد ذلك تركيا ثم ايران والان وصلنا
الى مرحله المفاهمه في اليمن هذه
الترتيبات المهمه هدفها الاساسي كلما خفض
التصعيد في المنطقه هنا لانه في السابق
مرحله الستينات وما بعد كان هنالك مرحله
الحرب البارده فكانت كتلتين الكتله
الغربيه بقياده الولايات المتحده والكتله
الشرقيه بقياده الاتحاد السوفيتي ف الدول
العربيه بعضها تنضوي تحتها الجانب الشرقي
او الجانب الغربي ولكن في بعد مرحله 2015
استشعر سمو الكريم ان الدور الغربي
الامريكي في المنطقه بدا يتراجع وبدات
التزاماتهم لا يتم الوفاء بها كما كان
معتاد او على الاقل هنالك مفاهمات تاريخيه
في هذا الجانب فوجد ان من الاسطح اعاده
تنظيم وترتيب العلاقه لكن لسبب لان
المملكه لا يوجد لديها اطماع تدخليه او
توسعيه في اي من هذه الدول وهذا الاتجاه
على فكره تبنته ايضا دول اخرى في المنطقه
مهمه مثل تركيا تركيا بدل ما يعني غيرت
موقفه فيما يتعلق بسوريا غيرت موقع يعني
دكتور سناتي عليها لكن لكن في موضوع تراجع
الدوره الامريكي هل يمكن القول اليوم مثلا
بين تراجع الدوري الامريكي في الشرق
الاوسط وهو ربما حتى ايضا تحدث فيه الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في فتره سابقه بان
الولايات المتحده ستعود الى الشرق الاوسط
الى ان الدوره الامريكي تراجع فعلا في
المنطقه هل ترى الدكتور بانه افضل
بالضروره لدخول لاعب جديد مهم شرقي في
المنطقه نتحدث هنا عن الصين وما حدث منها
كوسيط لاعاده العلاقات بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايران يعني العلاقه مع
الصين علاقه مهمه جدا على المستوى العربي
هنالك اكثر من 350 مليار دولار والصين
بدات تلعب دور مهم جدا السؤال هو اللي
يطرح نفسه انا بالنسبه لي ان الازمه
الاوكرانيه هي من سوف يحدد اذا هنالك عوده
لمرحله الحرب البارده او لن يكون هنالك
عوده لمرحله مرحله الحرب البارده بمعنى لو
انتصرت روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا فهذا
سوف يشجع الصين في الاندفاع نحو تايوان
ويضعف من الدور الامريكي الغربي في هذا
الجانب وندخل مرحله حرب بارده جديده اذا
لم تنتصر روسيا في حربا في اوكرانيا فهذا
يعني ان الهيمنه الامريكيه الغربيه سوف
تظل قائمه
سوف يضعف ايضا من دور الدور الصيني الصيني
بلد لها علاقه اقتصاديه قويه مع الدول
العربيه ومع المملكه بالذات المملكه
الشركه الاكبر والاهم بالنسبه لها والدور
السياسي الصيني الجديد مرحب به بكل معنى
الكلمه لان المملكه قبلت بالوساطه الصينيه
فيما يتعلق بالازمه الايرانيه كطرف ضامن
للسلوك الايراني وما ينتج عنه من تصرفات
دكتور يعني اليوم هالبات من الضروري اتجاه
الدول الاقليميه الكبرى في المنطقه تحدث
هنا عن الشرق الاوسط الاتجاه للتهدئه
للاستقرار يعني هل هي تنم عن حاله عدم
الاستقرار الدوليه التي خلفتها الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه احتمال نشوب ازمات
جديده بسبب تداعيات هذه الحرب في الشرق
الاوسط اما ان خيار المشاريع التنمويه
والاقتصاديه
والاتجاه ايضا الى تسويه الخلافات هو
مرتبط بهذه الحاله من التهدئه
يعني شو بالتاكيد المملكه تولي التنميه
والاقتصاد اهميه كبرى حتى قرارها فيما
يتعلق بقضايا النفط هو مبني على قرارك
اقتصادي له علاقه بمشاريع التنميه في
المملكه والازدهار في المنطقه بشكل عام
هذه الدول بدات تحدو نفس الحدو التركي
ارادت ان تصفر مشاكلها ايضا مع دول الجوار
بالنسبه لها ايران الان اراده ان تعيد
علاقتها لانها اصبحت مشغوله باوضاع
اقتصاديه ومترديه في داخلها العراق بدا
يهتم باعاده الاصلاح الداخلي ومحاربه
الفساد والاهتمام بوضع الدينار وكذا
فشعروا ان التوجه المملكه في التركيز على
التنميه الاقتصاديه هو التوجه الصحيح
ولذلك هذه الدول تحدث نفس الحدوه الذي
تبنته المملكه من هذا الطرح المملكه هي
تقود الان دفه هذا التوجه المهم جدا
بالنسبه للتنميه والاقتصاد والانسان
بالشكل الاكبر والاهم فايضا هذه الدول
حينما تبنت هذا المملكه فتح ذراعيها رح
الان باعاده ترتيب الامور للسببين اللي
قلت لك اياها هذا يفرض ايضا على دول
المنطقه ان يكون لديها الحمايه الذاتيه
وان لا تعتمد على مصادر خارجيه في توفير
الحمايه العلاقه وهي لا تريد على فكره دول
منطقه والخليج بالذات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لا تريد ان تكون طرفا في حرب
بارده قادمه لا تريد ان تنحاد الا هي تريد
ان تحتفظ بعلاقاتها المتميزه الاقتصاديه
مع الصين تريد ان تكون لها علاقه سياسيه
والامنيه العسكريه مع الولايات المتحده
ومع المعسكر الغربي ايضا تريد ان تحتفظ
بعلاقه قويه وجيده مع روسيا التي تشترك
معها في قضايا الطاقه وقضايا مهمه فايجاد
هذا التوازن يتطلب اعاده ترتيب البيت
اقليميا يتطلب تنسيق المواقف حل المشاكل
التركيز على التنميه وهنا السؤال المهم يا
دكتور يعني تسويه الخلافات بين دول
المنطقه
يعني فيها الكثير من القضايا الرئيسيه وال
العالقه التي يعني دعنا نقول لا يمكن حلها
من خلال يعني
محادثات قصيره مثلا او او مده قصيره لان
القضايا كبيره جدا يعني كيف سيتم التعامل
معها في تنظيم علاقات هذه الدول بين بعضها
البعض هل ستبقى مثلا هذه الخلافات مثلا
مؤجله وتبقى عالقه
ومحاوله الحفاظ ربما على التهدئه على
الاستقرار تنظيم اي خلافات ان ترى غير ذلك
يا دكتور خلينا ناخذ مثال المملكه حينما
انفتحت على تركيا واستقبلت الرئيس التركي
وزار سموني العهد الى تركيا الان هنالك
حوار سياسي تركي سعودي مستمر وموجود
فتنظيم لكن الاساس والرغبه الاكيده عند
الطرفين في حل الخلافات والانتقال الى
مفاهمه تضمن مصالح الطرفين المملكه لم تعد
تقبل فرض املاءات عليها ولم تعد تقبل ان
تكون الطرف الاضعف في التفاوض او في
المنظور المصالح هي تريد ت في العلاقه
مصالح مشتركه هذه ربما تاخذ وقتها ولكن
طالما ان الهدف الاساسي موجود وقائم وهو
الترتيب العلاقه الاقليميه وعلاقه متوازنه
المملكه اخذت موقف من تركيا حينما كان
هنالك استعداد تركي لمصر واستخدام الاخوان
المسلمين في مواجهه مصر لكنها حينما بدات
الحصن من علاقتها مع مصر وتعيد ترتيب
العلاقه معها المملكه رحلت بهذا الجانب
وبالامس كان هنالك لقاء لمعالي نائب وزير
الخارجيه السعودي معنا ابو وزير الخارجيه
التركي اجتماع سياسي حول الاجنده السياسيه
المشتركه فيما بين الطرفين ايضا مع ايران
المملكه رحبت يعني دائما كانت تقول نريد
الحوار المباشر مع ايران ورحبت بالدور
الصيني كطرف ضامن في هذا الجانب رحبت
بزياره وفد سعودي الى صنعاء مع وفد عماني
ايضا للمفاهمه حول ترتيب الامور واطلاق
سراح الرهائن والاسرى العفو الاسرى وايضا
الانتقال الى مرحله جديده ومهمه في حوار
يمني يمني هي هذا يخدم المصلحه الاقليميه
يخدم التنميه يخدم المشاريع الكبرى يخدم
الاستقرار لانه شعرنا في المنطقه هنا ان
العنصر الخارجي الذي كان يتدخل في عمليات
ترتيب الامن الاقليمي لم لم ياتي بنتيجه
ولم يؤدي هذا الدور واصبح كل طرف من مصلحه
جميع الاطراف ان ترتب على قتل اقليميه
فيما بينها طيب انت تقصد بهذا الطرف
الولايات المتحده دكتور الولايات المتحده
بالتاكيد لانها هي كانت يعني الولايات
المتحده من 57 ميلادي وتواجدها بعد موضوع
قناه السويس والانسحاب البريطاني الفرنسي
كانت هي موجوده ولكن تو موجوده في ذلك
الوقت كان يتزامن ايضا مع الوجود السوفيتي
مكان بمعنى انه كان هنالك مرحله الحرب
البارده الان زي ما قلت لك اصبحت هي هي
لاعب طرف اساسي هنالك قضايا كبرى ولذلك
الولايات المتحده في بعض الاحيان يعني
يدعون انه اعاده تشكيل القوى اعاده موضع
القوات تخفيض نسب بالرغم انه في الفتره
الاخيره لاحظنا ان هنا نوايا كبيره
امريكيه لاعاده ملا الفراغ والتواجد مره
اخرى بشكل السؤال هل نضمن هذه التحركات
الجديده التي تقوم بها سواء وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه او الخارجيه او السياسه
الامريكيه في المنطقه هنا هل لدينا
الاطمئنان الكامل ام نحن نريد ان نكون
متاكدين من انفسنا بمعنى بناء قدراتنا
وبناء القدرات على فكره لو لاحظت المملكه
اتجهت الى التصنيع العسكري الى الى
التدريب العالي لافرادها والقوات المسلحه
لانها لا تريد الاعتماد فقط على العنصر
الخارجي وانما بناء القدرات بما في ذلك
التصنيع والتمكين من القدرات وهذا بشكل
بشكل اهميه كبيره اشكرك جزيل الشكر
الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث شكرا دكتور
قال البيت الابيض ان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جاك سوليفان تحدث الى ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان وناقش عده
موضوعات من بينها شان الايراني والخطوات
الراميه لانهاء الحرب في اليمن
التقى ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان في جده عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
السيناتور لينزي كراههام وافادت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه انه جرى خلال الاجتماع
استعراض علاقات الصداقه بين البلدين وعدد
من المسائل ذات الاهتمام المشترك
عقب لقائه بولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان وصف السيناتور جراهام على حسابه
في تويتر الاجتماع بالمثمر وان تعزيز
العلاقات بين السعوديه والولايات المتحده
امر واعد للطرفين كما اكد جراهام على انه
يتطلع للعمل مع الاداره الامريكيه لتطوير
العلاقات بين البلدين والذي سيعود بفائده
اقتصاديه هائله للبلدين ويساهم في استقرار
المنطقه واعرب جراهام كذلك عن تقديره
لشراء السعوديه طائرات بقيمه 37 مليار
دولار لشركه الطيران السعوديه الجديده
اعلن رئيس فريق التفاوض اليمني التابع
للحكومه عن تاجيل تنفيذ تبادل الاسره بين
الحكومه والحوثيين يوما واحدا الى الجمعه
وكان الفريق الحكومي المعني بالمفاوضات قد
اشار الى ان عمليات تبادل الاسرى ستشمل
رحلات جويه بين العاصمه صنعاء وعدن ومناطق
اخرى في اليمن بالتنسيق مع اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر كما اكد ان الاستعدادات
اكتملت
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل
مدير الامن العام السعودي يؤكد تحقيق خطط
العمره لاهدافها خلال شهر رمضان
حياكم الله من جديد مكتبه الكتب
والمخطوطات النادره بالمسجد النبوي تزخر
بالكثير من المؤلفات بشتى المجالات
الشرعيه والعلميه التي يعود تاريخ البعض
منها الى السادس من الهجره اذ يحرصوا
الباحثين وزوار المسجد على زياره المكتبه
بالمعرفه من خلال المراجع الموثوقه تفاصيل
برفقه الزميل سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
تتنفس هذه الارفف المزدحمه بالكتب النادره
التاريخ الاسلاميه والعلوم الشرعيه وشتى
المجالات العلميه المختلفه والتي يحتضنها
المسجد النبوي ويعود تاريخ البعض منها الى
عده قرون عدد الكتب يزيد عن 7000 كتاب
جميعها مرقمنه يستطيع ان يستفيد منها
الباحث هو الزائر اما عن طريق الاطلاع او
عن طريق
الرقمنه بحيث انه يستطيع ان يحصل على نسخه
من هذه الكتاب اقدم هذه الكتب عمره ما
يقارب 200 سنه يحرص الباحثون وزوار المسجد
النبوي على التردد على هذه المكتبه للتزود
بالمعلومات والمراجع الموثوقه لاستكمال
ابحاثهم والتزود بالمعرفه ممكن تحصل في
هذه الاداره على كتب وتجدها هنا غير
موجوده في المكتبات الاخرى لان اسمها
الكتب النادره وهي الان هنا محفوظه معتنى
بها ولها برامج
ترميم وبرامج تعقيم
في الجانب الاخر قسم خاص بالمخطوطات
الاسلاميه القديمه والثمينه التي يرجع
تاريخها الى القرن السادس الهجري ويقصد
بالمخطوطات الاسلاميه التراث الاسلامي
المكتوب بخط اليد وقد عنيى المسلمون
بالمخطوطات عنايه كبيره لكونها السبيل
الوحيده للحفاظ على ما انتجه العقل
الاسلامي
في اداره المخطوطات اكثر من 4000 مخطوط
اصلي واكثر من 500 مصحف مخطوط اصلي يعتنى
فيها وتعرض لي الزوار والباحثين وطلاب
العلم يشهدوا المسجد النبوي منذ مطلع شهر
رمضان اعدادا مليونيه بعد التشغيل بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود مقدمه كافه
الخدمات بمختلف اشكالها للتسهيل على
المصلين والزوار من المسجد النبوي سلطان
السلمي العربيه
اكد مديره الامن العام السعودي الفريق
محمد البسامي خلال المؤتمر الصحفي الثاني
لقيادات امن العمره اكد بان خطط العمره
حققت اهدافها وجاهزون للتعامل مع الكثافات
مضيفا بان الاولويه للمعتمرين والكثافه في
اوقات الفروض البسامي اضافه خلال المؤتمر
الصحفي بانه تم ضبط سبعه او 47 حمله عمره
وهميه في مختلف المناطق
الاف المعتمرين والزوار يتوافدون يوميا
خلال شهر رمضان الى مسجد السيده عائشه
والمعروف بالتنعيم ويقع على حدود مكه من
الجهه الشماليه الغربيه حيث يعد احد
المعالم الاسلاميه المعروفه والمشهوره
فيها وميقات الحجاج والمعتمرين القادمين
من المدينه ويشهد كثافه عاليه في موسمي
الحج والعمره
[موسيقى]
مسجد السيده عائشه بنت ابي بكر الصديق له
مكانه خاصه بين مساجد مكه المكرمه
التاريخيه اذ يستقبل المعتمرين طيله العام
وعلى مدار الساعه
[موسيقى]
سمي مسجد التنعيم او مسجد العمره وهو احد
المعالم الاسلاميه المعروفه فهو ميقات
الحجاج والمعتمرين من اهل مكه المكرمه
سواء من سكانها او من المقيمين
[موسيقى]
يقع مسجد عائشه في الجهه الشماليه الغربيه
من مكه على بعد 7 كيلو متر عن المسجد
الحرام شمالا على طريق مكه المكرمه
والمدينه المنوره وهو اقرب موضع لحد الحرم
غاده الفهد العربيه مكه
من المدينه المنوره ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سلطان
السلمي
سننتظر الزميل سلطان الريتماتيج طبعا صوره
الزميل سلطان سلطان مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض الاجواء
رائعه وجميله خلفك احكي لنا اول شيء عن
الاجواء يا سلطان
بالفعل يعني استمتع اهالي وزوار المدينه
المنوره منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى بزخات
المطر من خفيفه الى متوسطه كما يظهر
امامكم الان الاجواء غائمه كليا وزخات
المطر لا تتوقف عن الهطول منذ تمام الساعه
العاشره صباحا لذلك يشهد المسجد النبوي
الان اعداد كبيره من المصلين والزوار سوف
يقصدون المسجد في هذه الساعات للاستمتاع
بالاجواء الماطره وكذلك الصلاه بالمسجد
النبوي اليوم
انخفاض ملحوظ في درجات الحراره بشكل واضح
منذ مساء البارحه وازدادت انخفاض درجه
الحراره في ساعات الصباح الاولى لكن في
زاويه مختلفه من المدينه هذا اليوم من
وتحديدا محطات الباص السياحي هنا في
المدينه المنوره نتحدث على اكثر من 12
محطه باص باص سياحي يقوم باخذ الزوار
والمصلين في رحله رحله سياحيه تختصر تاريخ
المدينه المنوره في ظرف لا يتجاوز 120
دقيقه هذه الحافله تقوم بالمرور
باثنى عشره معلما تاريخي واسلامي وتراثي
هنا في المدينه المنوره من خلال جولات
صباحيه ومسائيه عبر هذا الباص السياحي
المكشوف الذي تم تجهيزه وتهيئه الذي
الحافلات لاخذ الزوار المصلين في جولات
سياحيه وتاريخيه وثقافيه نتحدث انه يتم
ترجمه كافه المزارات ب 12 لغه عالميه
ليستطيع المصلي والزائر ان يعيش هذه
المرحله وهذه الحقبه التاريخيه عبر هذه
الحافله السياح السياحيه نتحدث على خمس
حافلات في المدينه المنوره تجوب شوارع
المدينه المنوره والمناطق التاريخيه
والاثريه منذ الساعات الصباح الاولى
وتحديد في تمام الساعه العاشره وحتى تمام
الساعه العاشره مساء ان تتراوح اسعار
التذاكر ما بين 25 ريال الى 45 ريال تم
تهيئه هذه الحافله
ووسائل السلامه والتكييف وكافه الخيارات
التي يستطيع من خلالها
السائحه والزائر الاستفاده هذه المداخل هي
للترجمه هنالك 12 لغه يستطيع من خلالها
الزائر الاستماع الى المعلومات التاريخيه
والثقافيه على المزارع السياحي او
الاسلامي والاستماع الى هنالك مرشدين
سياحيين يتواجدون في هذه الحافلات
السياحيه
لمساعده الزوار والاستمتاع ايضا مثل هذه
المحطات تنتشر في 12 موقع استطيع من
خلالها
الزائر او المصلي الحجز عبر الاون لاين او
حتى بشكل مباشر من هذه المحطات عن طريق
لعب او حتى عن طريق النقد ايضا نتحدث انه
اليوم الزوار يعني يحرصون بشكل كبير وملفت
جدا على التنقل عبر هذه الحافله السياحيه
لزياره المزارات السياحيه مثل جبل احد
ومقبره البقيع وكذلك جاده او مس جد قبه
وساحه الشهداء وغيرها من المواقع الاثريه
المهمه التي تسخر بها المدينه المنوره منذ
تاريخ او منذ القدم اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
هذه الجوله استمتع في الاجواء الرائعه
سلطان اخبطك عليها صراحه المدينه المنوره
مراسل العربيه السلطان سليمه شكرا يا
سلطان
الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها ايضا بعد
قليل
الاعلام المرئي والمسموع في السعوديه
يكشف عن رصد اكثر من اربعه الاف مخالفه
خلال الربع الاول من العام الجاري
حياكم الله من جديد نعود مره اخرى الى
مراسل العربيه من مكه المكرمه نواف عزيز
نواف مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض وانت في صحن المطاف
نريد اولا الحديث عن تفاصيل المؤتمر
الصحفي ابرز ايضا التصريحات لقيادات امن
العمره التي رصد تنوع
نعم نايف اهلا بك المؤتمر الصحفي الثاني
لقيادات قوات امن العمر الذي عقد مساء امس
في مكه المكرمه اعطى صوره واضحه عن الشكل
الذي سيكون عليه المسجد الحرام والمنطقه
المركزيه وحتى مكه المكرمه بشكل عام خلال
الايام العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان والتي
نشهدها الان مدير الامن العام الفريق محمد
البسامي اكد بان قوات امن العمره حققت
جميع اهدافها خلال فتره رمضان منذ بدايه
شهر رمضان وحتى يوم العشرين من رمضان واكد
ايضا بان قوات امن العمره جاهزه للتعامل
مع اي كثافات من خلال الخطط التنظيميه
الانتشار في داخل المسجد الحرام بشكل
تنظيمي لتنظيم المعتمرين والمصلين
بالاضافه الى مركز القياده والسيطره الذي
يرصد بشكل لحظي
البلاغات ويتعامل معها بتوجيه الفرق
الميدانيه الى مثلا اماكن الازدحام او اي
عوائق اخرى تتطلب التدخل الامني او
التنظيمي بينما اتحدث معكم ساترك لكم
الصوره من الصحن المطاف ايضا نايف مدير
الامن العام اكد بان الجهات الامنيه ضبطت
في العاصمه المقدسه اكثر من الف وسبعمائه
متسول بالاضافه الى ضبط 47
حمله وهميه للعمره على مستوى مناطق
السعوديه مشاركه ايضا من الدفاع المدني
مدير عام الدفاع عن المدني اللواء حمود
الفرج اكد بان انتشار فرق الدفاع المدني
في المسجد الحرام والمنطقه المركزيه وبشكل
عام في
المناطق التي تشهد ذروه في هذه
اضافه الى اجراء خمسه الاف جوله تفتيشيه
لفرق الدفاع المدني للكشف على المواقع
التجاريه هو ايضا السكنيه هو الخدميه
للتاكد من تواجد ادوات السلامه
ورصد اي ملاحظات حول ذلك هناك ايضا مشاركه
من الجوازات في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقد
يوم امس نائب مدير عام الجوازات اكد ايضا
بان التواجد يتم بشكل مكثف على جميع
المنافذ البريه والبحريه
والجويه في السعوديه لتقديم الخدمه
للمعتمرين والزوار في هذه الفتره وجهنا
سؤال نايف الى مدير الامن العام يوم امس
حول بعض المخالفات في القياده في مكه
المكرمه والمنطقه المركزيه التي ربما تعرض
سلامه المعتمرين والزوار للخطر خلال هذه
الفتره وقال بان الجهود المروريه في مكه
المكرمه والمنطقه المركزيه تتم بشكل مكثف
واكد انه يتم العمل على اعاده انسنه بعض
الاماكن خاصه في المنطقه المركزيه لتسهيل
عبور
المشاه خلال التوجه الى المسجد الحرام او
العوده منه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من مكه
المكرمه مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز
اجرى المركز السعودي لاستطلاعات الراي
العام استطلاع حول العادات اليوميه للناس
في رمضان في اسلوب الافطار وتوقيت النوم
بالاضافه الى مشاهده التلفاز توصل الى ان
سته وثلاثين بالمئه يفضلون تناول وجبه
واحده قبل صلاه المغرب كما ان واحد
واربعين من العينه لا يفضلون النوم في
الليل وعلى صعيد مشاهده البرامج
التلفزيونيه اكثر من نصف العينه لا تشاهد
التلفاز في رمضان
في الاستديو المشرف على مركز الوطني
للاستطلاعات الراي عبد السلام الوايه حياك
الله
اهلا وسهلا فيك خليني اسالك اولا ايش
تعليقك على كل هذه النتائج وهل انت جزء من
من سبق ذكرهم في هذا التقرير لا طبعا
الاغلبيه يعني
كممارسه في بعض الاسئله لكن هو استطلاع
اجرينا والعام السنه الماضي والسنه هذه
بنفس الاسئله وشبيه بصراحه نعم طلعت
النتائج الغريب ثابته
باستثناء يمكن عنصر واحد هو اللي تغير لكن
العادات يبدون يمكن لانه لازال الطقس
معتدل رمضان السنه الماضي السنه في دراسه
في الاجابات متقاربه يمكن الفارق الوحيد
هو في قضيه انه الوجبات في انتقال في شفت
من من وجبه واحده قبل الفطور السنه
الماضيه كانت
50% الصناديق 36 بالمئه
اللي قبل الصلاه بعدين صار في انتقال 14%
راحوا لخيار وجبه قبل صلاه المغرب وجبه
بعد التراويح
يا فصار في ما ادري ليش صار في هذه
الزياده يمكن في تغير شوي بالعادات ولا
علشان الليل طال فالنصر وياخذوا اساليب
الناس يا دكتور في رمضان
اتحدث عن الاسلوب النوم الافطار العادات
هل هي مرتبطه مثل ما ذكرت بالطقس ولا
مرتبطه بشكل يعني جماعي يتعودوا عليه
الناس من ازمنه طويله فبالتالي هو تكرار
روتين ممارسه الاستطلاعات فيها القضايا
اليسلوكيات الناس متقاليد اللي هي بمواضيع
يعني تطلب المؤسسات وانما ملاحظه ما هي
موجوده في المجتمع السعودي من زمان فاحنا
محتاجين دوره كامله تعرف رمضان ياخذ له كل
30 سنه يدور على كل الفصول فلو لو جمعنا
البيانات ذي على مستوى ثلاثين سنه
هل رمضان وقت انه ما في دراسه يختلف
سلوكيات الناس لما يكون في دراسه رمضان
لما يجي وقت الصيف اللي هو النهار طويل
والليل قصير يختلف عن النهار سلوكيات
الناس بيختلفون لما يكون في الشتاء النهار
قصير والليل طويل فاحنا محتاجين دوره
كامله
في رمضان يعني النوم في رمضان في الليل
يكاد يكون شبه معدوم اغلب الناس يعني
والماضيه نصف العينه ينامون بعد ثلاث
الفجر او ما ينامون بالليل ففيه ثبات في
قضيه انه متاخر نصف العينه لكن داخل اللي
اللي بعد ثلاث بالليل فيه اختلاف بين
السنه الماضيه وهذه انه زادوا اللي ما
يعلمون نهائيا بالليل وفي ناس يا دكتور
في رمضان
وهذه عينه مش مش قليله بصراحه خصوصا من
صغار السن يعني او حتى اللي يعني بين عمر
سبع سنين و14 سنه الدخول المتغير جديد غير
قضيه الطقس والدراسه اللي هم ما بعد
كورونا اللي هو الساعه المرنه كثير من
الاماكن العمل صارت تعطي ساعه او ساعتين
مرنه ممكن تبدا دوامك عشره ممكن تبدا 11
ممكن تبدا خمس ساعات مثلا او ست ساعات
فهذا ايضا ازاد زاد مرونه في قضيه برنامج
النوم
ويمكن يصير هذا مؤثر بشكل كبير بس التغير
الكبير نبي ننتظر لما يجي رمضان وقت عطله
من الدراسه ما في دراسه نبي نشوف عادات
السعوديين لكن الوقت يا دكتور قبل تقريبا
سنتين يعني الناس ما كانت عندها خصوصا
الطلاب
العام فيه دراسه نفس الشيء قبل سنتين
تقريبا
انه ما كان في دراسه في رمضان فتره سنوات
يعني
طويله كانت صادف وقت الاجازه الصيف لما
تصور الصيف
يا دكتور نفس العاد ما تتغير حتى مع دخول
يعني الدراسه والجدول
يعني الدراسيه في شهر رمضان
في المركز الوطني استطلاع الراي انه انه
لاحق سنويا بنفس الاسئله والمتغيرات يعني
العادات عندنا نفس الشيء ننفذ الان البارح
واليوم عن قضيه العيد كيف سيقضي العيد نفس
الاسئله اللي سالناه العام
المرور هذا السنه سلوكيات المرور
القراءه معرض الكتاب حق الرياض السنه
الماضيه والسنه عادي اسال نفس الاسئله
وفيه زياده مضطرده ليس في الوسائل
الالكترونيه فقط بل في تغلب الجوال حتى
على التابلت وعلى الكمبيوتر وعلى كذا فكل
ما يزيد سنه بعد
اكثر من 53
انتقال للتطبيقات يعني شاهد فهذه هي اللي
صايره زياده
بطريقه مختلفه بس السنه ذي في زياده
مشاهده العام قليله يمكن اربعه بالمئه
واذنها يمكن عشان قد يكون عشان
انضم الي في الاستوديو المشرف على الوطني
لاستطلاعات الراي عبد السلام الوائل شكرا
في مدينه عرعر شمال السعوديه دابت عائلته
الرقبه في مبادره امتدت لعشر سنوات على
ابطال الصائمين في شهر رمضان هذه المبادره
التي نالت اهتم اهتمام كثير من السعوديين
يشاركها الجيران باحضار بعض الاطباق
بمنازلهم التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
في مبادره امتدت لعشر سنوات
ذهبت عائله الركبي في مدينه عرعر بمنطقه
الحدود الشماليه السعوديه على افطار
الصائمين طيله شهر رمضان هذه المبادره
ابتدا بها والدي رحمه الله عليه حمد من
عشر سنوات ونحن ان شاء الله مستمرون بهذه
المبادره والحمد لله العائله كلها من
كبيرها الى صغيرها نشارك في اعداد هذه
الماء الدبابه الجماعيه وكلهم خليه نحل
داخلي لا احكي لك كيف يعملون من الظهر الى
تقديم الوجبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه المبادره التي لقيت صدى واسعا يشاركها
الجيران باحضار بعض الاطباق من منازلهم في
اجواء تسودها المحبه
المجموع اشبعتوهم ورويتم تربون من الجنه
انتم والديكم ولد والديكم جميع المسلمين
انا في شهر كان والله ماني من هالديره انا
من نهر الرياض
جبت اليوم شوربه ولبن وخره الله
تنسطر هنا والجماعه ما بيقصروش معنا الله
يجازيهم الخير ويفطرونا على طول وكل سنه
وهم طيبين
واهل كرم واهل خير الناس كلها بتيجي تفطر
هنا وبتطلع مبسوطه واحلى فطار اصناف
متنوعه من الاطعمه الرمضانيه يتم طهيها في
مطبخ هذه العائله التي تكاتفت على تجهيز
الافطار من الكبار والصغار
العائله تجهز السمبوسه كذلك الشوربه
الوجبه الرئيسيه اللي هي الرز الكبسه هذه
الوجبه الرئيسيه السعوديه كذلك الايدامات
محلبيه حسب المتوفر في هذا اليوم من الصنف
الحاله
والعصائر والالبان
[موسيقى]
من مدينه عرعر جزاع النصي العربيه
اعلنت الاعلام الماليه والمسموح في
السعوديه خلال الربع الاول من العام
الحالي عن رسلي اكثر من 4000 مخالفه
اعلاميه تنوعت بين مخالفات النشر
الالكتروني للمحتوى الاعلامي والتعصب
الرياضي وممارسه العمل الاعلامي دون ترخيص
وكشفت الهيئه عن اكثر من 1700 طلب استدعاء
للمخالفين للتحققي من المخالفه
يواصل مسلسل منه ولدنا اثنين كسب ثقه
المشاهد السعودي والخليجي على حد سواء
تصدرت مشاهدات المسلسل والنقاشات حول قصته
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي المزيد في فقرات
كواليس مع سهى الوعل وعد اليهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
مو عيب اننا نطيح يلا يا ولد نزل الشنطه
واخيرا القصه التي لا تشبه كل القصص
[موسيقى]
مرحبا من رمضان الماضي استطاع مسلسل منه
ولد
نا قاعده جماهيريه كبيره حيث قدم جيل
تلفزيوني جديد من نجوم الكوميديا الشباب
الجزء الجديد جاء من زاويه مختلفه فبعد ما
كانت القصه تدور فقط في جزء الاول عن
الشابين اتبدلوا وقت الولاده وما ترتب على
ذلك
ركز الجزء الجديد على امور اخرى كطموحات
كل منهما وكيف دمرت احداهما الاخرى
بيكون في شيء اصعب يعني او انه لازم احنا
نصير احسن او هم يصيرون احسن انا احس كل
فريق او كل عمل له جوا وكل ناس او يعني كل
ناس لهم لهم الاشياء اللي يحبونها
يعني اتجه الى منحنى مختلف تماما عن الجزء
الاول وبيكون واضح بالنسبه للمشاهد الجزء
الاول ممكن كان التركيز اكثر شي على
الكوميديا بينما الجزء الثاني لتفرع
وراح اتجاه النصر الى عده امور ولكن ما
تخلو من الكوميديه الكوميديا موجوده ولكن
المستوى الدرامي اصبح اكثر من الكوميديا
ولكن بطريقه لطيفه وخفيفه على المشاهد
المسلسل بحسب تصنيفات شاهد استطاع انه
يحترم مركز الرابع في السعوديه من ناحيه
ارقام المشاهده اسهم في ذلك بحسب راي
النقاط توقيت عرضه مباشره بعد مسلسل طاش
في الفتره الذهبيه طبعا هو نجاح الموسم
الاول
حملنا مسؤوليه كبيره
كان نجاح كبير وعظيم والحمد لله رب
العالمين يعني
وصلنا فيه لمناطق كنا حابينها وصلنا لها
فالجزء هذا احنا في مسؤوليه علينا لازم
نكون نقدم افضل
من الجزء الاول فالجزء الثاني في مفاجات
حلوه في احداث جميله في تنوع شخصيات تنوع
احداث جدا جميله بصراحه عائله وحده ولا
الشارع قاعد يقدمها جدا جميل الحمد لله
تغير وتركتر بيني كريان وبين الاستاذ محمد
كان جميل جدا ليش للريان موسم الاول كان
قاسي معها تماما الين صار الدرس اللي هو
رجع العالم الفقر ثم رجع المكان الحقيقي
مع بعض التغريدات من هنا وهناك حول العالم
[موسيقى]
احنا حبيناك عشانك انت
انا حبيتك عشانك انت فلا تغير نفسك عشاني
[موسيقى]
من ابريل سيشاهد سيشاهد الهلال بالعين
المجرده في استراليا وماليزيا وسنغافوره
غير مرئي في باقي دول العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منذ لحظه ولاده هلال شهر رمضان والقمر
يسير خلف الشمس متجها من جهه الشرق الى
جهه الغرب محاولا بكل جديه ان يدرك الشمس
وسيدركها في صباح يوم الخميس 20 ابريل في
تمام الساعه 7:00 و12 دقيقه وحينئذ يولد
الهلال ولاده مشاهده على استراليا
وماليزيا وسنغافوره وشرق مدغشقر اللي كسوف
الشمس وولاده خفيه غير مشاهده على بقيه
بلدان العالم وفي مساء ذلك اليوم اللي هو
يوم الخميس سيكون للقمر مكسون قرابه النص
ساعه وعلى هذا الاساس فان رمضان لهذه
السنه سينتهي في يوم بدا فيه فقد بدا يوم
الخميس وسينتهي يوم الخميس والجمعه اول
ايام العيد سعيد على جل البلدان العربيه
والاسلاميه وكل عام وانتم بخير اهنئ
بالعيد من وجه ه هو العيد لولا حل طالعا
وادعو الى الله سبحانه بشمل يكون لنا
جامعه
[تصفيق]
والهلال لا يشاهد الا اذا تحققت اركانه
وتوافرت شروطه واهمها ان يولد الهلال قبل
مغيب الشمس وان يكون للهلال بعد مغيب
الشمس والهلال هلالين هلال للخاصه لا
يشاهده الا حديد البصر وهو التصوير وهذا
يكون يوم الخميس ليله الجمعه وهلال للعامه
يشاهده عامه الناس وهذا يكون يوم الجمعه
ليله السبت سنون تعاد ودهر يعيد لعمر كما
في الليالي جديد اضاء لادم هذا الهلال
فكيف تقول الهلال الوليد
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه
الخارجيه الايرانيه تعلن ان وفطا ايرانيا
وصل الى الرياض لاعاده فتح السفاره
والقنصليه
السنه يقول بانه يتطلع للعمل مع الاداره
والكونغرس لتعزيز العلاقات مع الرياض
الامن العام السعودي يعلن عن ضبط 47 حمله
وهميه للعمره في مختلف المناطق
عائله سعوديه تتولى اعداد وجبات الافطار
لعشرات الصائمين في عرعر منذ نحو عشره
اعوام
شكرا لكم لكرمي ولطف المتابعه الرابعه
انتهت اعود والقاكم غدا في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات